new information from witnesses on the
altercation that could have led to
yesterday's deadly shooting inside a
convenience store it happened at speedy
market just east of unlv near mcleod and
tropicana that's where we find victoria
saha with more details hi victoria
speedy mart is back open today after
being closed from the shooting while i
was here earlier i came across a witness
hotel who was here at the time of the
shooting she tells me it started based
on two customers arguing over who was
going to pay first
this witness is still shaken up from
yesterday she only agreed to speak with
me off camera she tells me she was
paying at the register then a young
woman was about to pay but a man said he
was next in line the witness says the
woman stepped back and apologized that's
when the man started yelling slurs and
threw a soda can at her police didn't
give us too many details but say after
the altercation with the customer the
woman left and came back with a man who
had a gun that man allegedly shot the
male customer and ran off with no
arrests made the community is on edge i
feel about it now i can't even leave my
house now
except for going to work the 48-year-old
man who was shot died at the hospital
those who live nearby say he was
homeless and would go to the speedy mart
often
police have not given us any information
on the suspect but you are asked to call
police if you have any information
reporting near mccloud and tropicana
victoria saha live local now